Людина в ХХІ столітті все менше й менше використовує
зéмлі для своєї господарської діяльності.
Основна ідея полягає в тому,
щоб якраз поступово такі землі повертати
до їхнього природного вигляду.
Цей парк був створений 2015 року
нашою командою ентузіастів.
Спочатку дуже сильно з пересторогою
ставились люди до цього проєкту,
тому що це перший такий проєкт,
саме коли природоохоронна діяльність
[є] повністю на приватних засадах.
Для того, щоб якось знайти натхнення,
ми відвідали в Угорщині парк.
І також у Нідерландах ми познайомились
якраз із ідеологією ревайлдингу.
[наганяє корів, супроводжуючи
це різними вигуками]
Це Чернігівська область,
вона не дуже густонаселена,
зазнала в деяких своїх частинах досить
інтенсивної меліорації, меліоративних робіт.
Тому ми вирішили,
що було б цікаво почати саме тут.
Наш парк можна розділити
на дві частини — нижню й верхню —
за рахунок цікавого ландшафту
і наших ярів.
Ну, взагалі територія парку
близько 400 га,
тому ходити тут багато.
Ви сьогодні приїхали в перший
ревайлдинг-парк в Україні.
Ревайлдинг — це відновлення типових екосистем
шляхом повернення
на цю територію крупних тварин.
Взагалі, травоїдні тварини мають
найбільший вплив на довкілля.
Ми почали якраз із процесу
природного випасу.
Якщо немає випасу на траві,
що відбувається?
Весь час ростуть нові трави,
потім восени вони жовтіють,
далі за зиму — вмирають,
і з'являється все більший і більший шар,
накопичується ця подушка,
і через неї нові молоді трави
не проростають так ефективно,
і відбувається деградація довкілля.
Найбільшими травоїдними тваринами
Європи були вимерлий прадавній тур,
тарпан — це предок сучасних коней.
Як приклад великої травоїдної тварини,
що збереглася, це ось у нас кулани,
які теж проживали колись
у степовій частині України.
Усі вони роблять ось такі
невеличкі галявинки,
витоптують їх і качаються в піску,
у такий спосіб захищаючись
від шкірних паразитів.
Тому що з піском вони
менше їх кусають,
мухи менше кусають.
Першого коника, якого ми
з вами побачимо, звуть Горіц.
Горіц у нас не простий кінь,
а чубарий леопардовий.
— Знаєте, що таке чубарий леопардовий?
— Ні!
Це така масть у нього.
Горіц у нас жеребець, тобто він —
хлопчик, і дуже-дуже красивий.
— Так.
— А скільки він важить?
Важить він багато, до 800 кг.
Ого!
А порода називається Норікер.
Норікер — це національна
порода Австрії.
Ось цього коника звуть
Блек Джек, це Гуцул.
Вони ходять по таких
вузеньких стежках,
де навіть людині
складно пройти.
Вони ще дуже сильні,
вони дуже витривалі і мужні.
І якщо немає гарної дороги,
на них люди їздили і до школи,
і в магазин, і навіть до лікарні.
Тому що такі віддані конячки
всюди вивезуть своїх господарів.
Бачите, ось далі навіть важкувато
йти, тобто суцільні хащі.
І це теж вплив природних процесів,
що ліс стає набагато відкритішим:
спочатку з'являються такі проходи,
а потім поступово-поступово
вони відкривають цілі галявини.
Навіть якщо ліс густий
або густо ростуть кущі й дерева,
то такі великі тварини як тури
або коні без проблем їх ламають.
Якраз кордон між відкритою місцевістю
і густим лісом — це ті місця,
де можна побачити найбільше тварин.
Наприклад, тих же самих
оленів, козуль, лосів.
Ще в нашому лісі ми
залишаємо всі дерева,
які природним шляхом впали,
або це були якісь вітровали,
або якщо це дерево від старості,
ми їх залишаємо.
Тому що там багато комах
розмножуються, живуть.
Ось гриби ростуть.
Ось зі збільшенням кількості комах
у нас збільшилась кількість пташок.
Найбільший хижий птах —
це орлан-білохвіст,
а так багато різних яструбів, лунів.
Крім діяльності «ревайлдинг», взагалі цей проєкт
також має на собі туристичну мету,
тому що треба теж знаходити
нові шляхи фінансування.
Для туристів у нас є перелік різних
диких екскурсій на природну територію.
Це просто екскурсія парком, спеціалізовані
екскурсії і вже індивідуальні екскурсії,
якщо людина хоче побути
ближче до природи.
Це екскурсії на цілий день
або на декілька днів.
У нас є оренда будиночків,
потім в нас є оренда наметів,
і також для людей, які хочуть приїхати
зі своїми наметами, в нас є кемпінг.
Також проводяться різні
фестивалі та свята,
наприклад, ми проводимо
фестиваль реконструкції.
Ми займаємось екологічною освітою,
ми співпрацюємо зі школами,
розказуючи їм про ревайлдинг
і про важливість охорони природи.
І також ми займаємось
культурною роботою,
розказуючи, наприклад,
про бортництво.
Зараз бортним способом
мед майже не добувають,
тому що так його десь втричі менше,
ніж зі звичайного вулика, можна добути,
і набагато більше треба
цим займатися.
Також тільки один раз на рік
можна видобувати мед,
а не двічі, а іноді тричі,
як це роблять на пасіках.
Бачите зверху красуню Клеопатру?
Клеопатра — рись європейська,
про яку я вам розповідала.
Бачите, яка вона гарна?
Які в неї стрункі ніжки сильні!
Який короткий хвостик!
Вони спокійно витримують
навіть низькі температури.
А завдяки тому, що між пальчиками
у них є такі перетинки,
вони можуть ходити навіть по снігу.
Бачиш, яка в них велика лапа?
У всьому світі змінюється
концепція заповідної справи,
що заповідники повинні
бути не тільки місцем,
де просто охороняється природа
і нічого не відбувається,
а змінюється принцип
взаємокористування.
Я думаю, що ця діяльність взагалі
теж якоюсь мірою спосіб життя,
тому що ті люди,
які хочуть щось робити
(не тільки брати, а й щось
робити для довкілля),
будуть залучатися все більше
й більше до якихось ініціатив,
наприклад, охорони природи
або якихось екологічних ініціатив.
Тоді це вже буде теж така природоохоронна
і ревайдлинг-мережа в Україні.